donc je pensit passercognito avec un
gros lutrin mais ça a l'air que non fait
évidemment j'ai mes feuilles euh en fait
je vais vous parler un peu de mon
parcours justement le 3 novembre 2013 ma
vie a complètement changé en fait je
suis devenu le plus jeune mère du Québec
c'est surtout ce que les gens ont retenu
mais je suis surtout devenu en tout
qu'est-ce qui me tient surtout à cœur
c'est que je suis le 15e maire de ma
petite municipalité clairement ou
clairement
e
merci en quelques semaines comme je vous
le disais plusieurs choses ont changé
mais surtout le regard des gens euh
justement on accordait du jour au
lendemain plus d'importance à ce que je
disais à mes opinion et à mes idées
pourtant j'étais exactement le même
avant ou après mon élection en fait on
ma même perçu pour dans le fond pour
être le représentant officiel de tous
les jeunes qui existent sur la terre on
m'appelait dès le 4 novembre sans joke
le matin même je dirais peut-être 6h là
mon Facebook ook mon
courrier le téléphone mais là le
téléphone cellulaire maison municipalité
dérougissait pas là on m'appelait de
partout au Québec et au Canada pour
faire des entrevues que ce soit à la
télé à radio ou même dans le journal
puis que ça soit en français ou en
anglaison je suis pas très bon en
anglais fait que ça donnait des trucs un
peu douteux mais je le faisais quand
même sa jusqu'à tempant que ça a duré
pendant à peu près 2 semaines puis làé
ben je me suis dit bon ben il faut
mettre des limites donc j'ai mis mes
propres limites parce que je pense que
je Seris encore là à parler au téléphone
donc dans le fond c'est ça je me suis
affirmé puis ben c'est ça j'ai j'ai
décidé de pu cement essayer de faire
plaisir à tout le
monde ce soir ce que je vais vous parler
c'est de faire sa marque pour moi ça a
deux significations particulières
d'abord que l'idée que l'on peut devenir
soi-même une marque mais aussi l'idée
que l'on peut en fait qu l'on veut tous
laisser une trace de notre passage dans
le monde donc ce que je vous propose ce
soir c'est de faire un
Pact mais là partez pas en peur là je su
pas en train de partir une
sec
jeer ça je veux pas que vous fassiez un
pacte avec moi je veux que vous en
fassiez un avec vous l'important c'est
que je vous propose pas le faire demain
la semaine prochaine dans un an mais ici
et maintenant le PACT c'est ce que je
mets en application dans ma vie depuis
2013 et ça c'est cette idée là a changé
ma façon d'aborder la
vie voici des gens qui ont en fait euh
atteint leur propre PCT des gens qui ont
choisi de perdre du poids ou de faire un
cheminement plus introspectif pour
prendre la place qui leur revenait tout
domaine confondu il n'y a qu'un pas
entre vous et eux la preuve ben je vais
vous en donner deux même je suis
généreux je je vous présente en fait mon
frère Martin et ma nièe Christiane qui
ont perdu énormément de poids tous les
deux pourtant ils sont pris de
différentes façons qui étaient vraiment
différent justement et leur but était
différent
également donc vous avez pas besoin de
d'être célèbre pour faire votre Mac vous
pouvez devenir des modèles pour votre
entourage mais là vous me demandez sans
doute c'est quoi le
pacte ben le pacte c'est un acronyme que
j'ai créé c'est pas la science infuse là
c'est c'est ma vision de voir les
choses puis on commence en fait avec le
avec le P bon le P pourquoi le P pour
pouvoir vous avez du pouvoir j'espère
que je vous apprends rien mais si c'est
le cas vous en avez peut-être que vous
ne l'utilisez pas ou que vous le
transmettez à d'autres sans le savoir
mais c'est sûr que vous en avez le
plusutôt vous allez en prendre
conscience le plusutôt vous allez
réussir à vivre heureux mais là
qu'est-ce que le bonheur vient faire
là-dedans mais fait selon une une
chercheuse qui a publié son étude dans
le psychology today 40 % de notre
capacité à accéder au bonheur réside
dans notre capacité à changer et nous
adapt 40 % là c'est énorme ça ça veut
dire que dans la tard du bonheur là il y
a 60 % de tout le reste 40 % juste pour
la dimension du
changement j'espère que vous avez fait
vot de voir si vous êtes pas à l'aise
avec le changement parce que vous aurez
pas la note de
passage faut être réaliste on peut pas
tout contrôler mais l'attitude que l'on
choisit nous appartient en fait c'est là
que se trouve votre pouvoir j'espère en
fait alors excusez-moi que ce soit un
changement provoqué ou non vous euh on
peut choisir d'être une victime ou
encore de se battre reprendre son
pouvoir peut se faire de façon
progressive euh sur des
aspect anod notre vie par exemple ça
peut être aussi simple que si j'arrive
en retard quelque part c'est de ma faute
même si je mon auto partait pas ou il y
avait des travaux j'avais la possibilité
de prévoir ça a l'air un peu niaiseux
mais juste ça ça vous permet de
reprendre le pouvoir qui vous appartient
et arrêter de le distribuer aux autres
donc on va continuer avec le
a pour
analyse tout le monde analyse son
environnement que ce soit un peu
informel voir même inconscient euh
parfois lorsque des choix importants se
se présentent à vous vous pensez
peut-être utiliser la technique des pces
qui est un peu plus répandu ce que je
vous propose c'est vraiment un un truc
plus administratif qui va aller plus
loin ça s'appelle la matrice FFOM bon
FFOM pour force faiblesse opportunité et
menace c'est un outil largement utilisé
comme je vous disais dans le monde de
l'administration pour l'environnement
d'une entreprise que ça soit interne ou
externe mais ça peut tout aussi bien
s'appliquer à une personne en fait on
peut faire le parallèle par exemple avec
les forces et faiblesses d'une marque et
les qualités défaut d'un individu quand
à l'environnement externe en fait c'est
tout ce qui vous touche sans que vous en
ayez en fait le contrôle
directement le but est d'avoir le
portrait de vous le plus complet
possible alors n'hésitez pas à ler le
plus éléments n'ayez pas peur de lister
en fait vos faiblesses parce que c'est
ça qui va vous permettre de progresser
dans le processus et d'évoluer justement
euh je vous recommande fortement de
faire l'exercice par écrit c'est un peu
comme une une image qui va vous
représenter en fait quand vous offrez
l'exercice dans un an ben ça va avoir
sûrement changé ça représente vraiment
un moment où vous vous trouvez vous
allez découvrir par écrit justement euh
vous allez faire des liens aussi que
vous avez peut-être pas vu euh
juste comme ça dans le fond vous allez
découvrir des potentiels que vous avez
pas nécessairement vu juste comme ça au
niveau de la stratégie en fait B c'est
juste de mettre tout ça ensemble de voir
s'il y a des liens que vous pouvez créer
est-ce que je suis capable de prendre
une force pour saisir une opportunité
une force pour réduire une menace est-ce
que je suis capable d'utiliser une
opportunité pour per à une faiblesse
puis finalement est-ce qu'il y a une
qu'il faudrait vraiment que j'élimine
pour pas être atteint par une
menace laè étape c'est le C donc le C
pourrait bien être pour la confiance
mais c'est pas ça c'est un conceptte
c'est vrai largement utilisé dans ce
genre de démarche mais moi pour faire é
un peu aux autres conférences j'ai
choisi le
courage ça prend du courage pour sortir
de sa zone de confort et de faire au
danger vous avez vous pouvez avoir toute
la la confiance du monde si vous n'avez
pas le courage de provoquer votre
changement vous allez rester avec la
stat et vous serez vulnérable au
changement
extérieur c'est bien be r en
couleur et c'est bien be en couleur que
on a confiance en nous mais c'est pas
instantané il y a toujours des
doutes vous voulez la
preuve est-ce que j'ai l'
confiant
hein je pense que une image vaut 1000
mots je bien croire que c en maternel
mais quand même tu sais j'étais l'élève
le plus gêné de tous et puis ben c'est
ça là
justement plus gêné de tous et la
confiance tacire en fait petit à petit
une raison pourquoi je suis là et
victoire après victoire on va se dire
les vrais affaires j'ai choisi le
courage parce que c'est ce que ça prend
pour déclarer la guerre mais déclarer la
guerre contre qui ou contre quoi ben
c'est simple contre votre pire
adversaire
vous-même il faut il ne faut
pas excuseer il ne faut pas s'avouer
vaincu trop vite il faut être créatif et
essayer de voir toutes les facettes d'un
problème ou d'une
opportunité si je prends par exemple
un projet que j'ai fait au CGF on a eu
plusieurs
embuches mais finalement on a quand même
réussi à avoir un prix régional pour
notre projet qui était en fait la
création d'un album de musique
d'artistes régionaux mais je vous a
pargne les détails là j'avais
quelques exemples mais en fait le
principal c'est que je me suis retrouvé
à à la fin du projet on a eu un problème
de raison à la dernière minute des
disques tu sais c'est comme un peu le
principal quand qu'on fait un album et
et on avait un lancement le samedi et le
vendredi finalement les disques ne sont
pas arrivés euh donc je me suis retrouvé
à poursuivre un camion de livraison de
de Rouin jusqu'à Valdor sans savoir si
les dis étaient vraiment dans ce camion
là j'étais vraiment crinqué là je
voulais faire mon lancement on s'entend
finalement ben c'était pas le bon
camion mais e écoute B ça j'étais
tellement crinqué que j'ai réussi à me
faufiler dans l'entrepôt puis j'ai
trouvé le bon camion pas pire hein fait
j'ai trouvé mes disques puis on a fait
le lancement pu ça c'est super bien
passé
hein pas besoin d'êre jeans bond là tu
sais on peut tout faire ça une
ensuite il y a le thé th pour oui th
pour trajet bon je sais ça fait
directement que je viens de vous conter
là mais en fait sans blague c'est la
partie la plus difficile que je trouve
pour moi parce que ça implique de vivre
dans le moment présent évidemment vos
buts sont une source majeure de
motivation toutefois le chemin qui nous
permet qui nous permet de lesteindre
peut être tout autant
vibrant je parlais aub au tout début de
ma conférence du pouvoir et bien chacun
de vous a plus ou moins d'influence sur
son entourage
vous pouvez même avoir l'impact dans la
vie d'un inconnu je vais vous conter
quelque chose durant ma
campagne j'ai rencontré un monsieur
d'une cinquantaine d'années disant
simplement que la politique c'était pas
son dada cétait pas sa passion
première mais à à force du parler à
force d'essayer de la convaincre de
voter pour
moi il m'a dit quelque chose qui m'a
vraiment touché il m'a dit bon tu sais
moi j'ai j'ai 50 ans là j'ai jamais voté
de ma vie j'ai pas voté fédéral
provincial autre scolaire municipale
n'importe mais pour toi tu me convaincu
je vais aller voter je vais aller
m'inscrire sur la liste électoraleit
juste ça c'est point là ça a justifié
toutes mes efforts dans ma campagne puis
ça a justifié justement que je sois tout
autant motivé jusqu'à la fin puis que
finalement je
réussisse
hein non excusez
c'est comme voyons qui qui me parle
ok ok le E donc dernière
étape en fait ça devrait être un e parce
que c'est évaluation le mot bon je sais
que ça devrait être donc un e dans mon
acronyme mais ça ferait
paacter je sais pas pourquoi mais ça
donne pas la même
image mais vous pouvez l'utiliser je
vous juge pas ça fait exactement même
chose sais c'est il marche quand même je
suis juste pas responsable des
conséquences euh pour l'établee
d'évaluation en fait est crucial oui à
la fin mais tout au long du processus
l'évaluation sert à desciler nos erreurs
et par conséquent les piste
d'amélioration qui se fait il faut il
faut jamais voir cette étape comme un
retour à la Cuse départ ça c'est très
important au contraire c'est signes que
l'on se connaît en fait de plus en plus
vous savez
au Québec une
bébit savez c'est quoi la
béb on a une BB qui s'appelle Andr
sauv parutre avec
meseve plus qu'unoris moi je vois
vraiment comme un véritable penseur vous
allez comprendre pourquoi en entrevue il
a déjà dit on ne change jamais on fait
juste devenir de mieux en mieux
soimême en fait je trouve C
vraiment intéressante pu ça illustre un
peu le propos que je vous partager
l'important quand qu'on fait face au
changement c'est surtout de jamais se
perd en chemin l'étape de l'évaluation
vous permet d'avoir une petite pause du
quotidien même 5 minutes pour vraiment
valider si vous aller dans la bonne
direction je v vous donner un autre
exemple la mairie clairement ça a jamais
fait partie de mes plans j'ai jamais
voulu avoir une carrière en politique
mais je l'ai fait parce que ça
m'interpellait puis parce que juste
c'était quelque chose qui venait me
chercher vraiment après ça j'ai eu plein
d'opportunités qui se sont ouver à moi
puis j'ai dû prendre un temps de
réflexion pour voir vraiment ce que je
voulais faire dans Vie finalement ben
j'ai j'ai déduit que j'avais pas
vraiment je voulais pas vraiment avoir
une carrière en politique donc j'ai
refusé plein d'offres et en fait je je
trouve ça quand même important de
s'affirmer euh pour pas se dénaturer tu
sais puis euh pour pas pour voyons
excuseer
ouais c'est ça ça fait directement éco
en fait c'est un cycle ça fait
directement é ch à la première partie du
pacte le
pouvoir donc si on revient justement
avec le PACT en terminant je tiens à
vous préciser que je vous encourage pas
à faire quelque chose que vous avez pas
envie de faire je vous encourage à faire
quelque chose que vous avez envie de
faire mais que vous avez
peur ça ça s'appelle la cognitive on va
un peu dans le terme plus psychologique
c'est la confrontation de deux idées
fortes qui vous crée un profond malaise
ça ça peut être très très puissant je
vous le dis pour éviter le danger vous
allez utiliser des stratégies
d'évitement donc par exemple j'aimerais
faire une
conférence mais je v trouver toutes les
raisons inimaginbles pour pas la
faire une
jamb ça pe être extrême sentend dépend
du degré du danger qu'on perçoit
euh donc c'est ça en fait je v faire
aussi un lien avec la peur Will Smith a
déjà dit bon évidemment en anglais
mais je vous dratu la peur n'est pas
réelle c'est une production
intellectuelle le fruit de votre P votre
imagination et ne vous m prenez pas le
danger lui est bien
réel mais la peur est un choix
au début de ma conférence je vous ai
proposé de faire un pacte avec vous-même
un Pact pour pouvoir analyse courage
trajet et évaluation oui c'est ça parce
ça fais
pacter vous avez ici maintenant oh ça
pas
changé bon voer mon punch euh vous avez
ici maintenant le pouvoir de choisir
d'être plus fort que vos pès et meilleur
que vous-même alors qu'attendez-vous
pour faire votre marque
merci